okay for people joining this live stream
we are looking at some incremental
language development for
language and we have an assortment of
topics today
as usual all right symmetric difference
yes so this is um this is something we
discussed
in a recent meeting and we decided that
we had to look at the possibilities
because there are several possibilities
here
so we can perhaps start by at the end a
section
where i propose the difference
because this is just examples and
examples so
the main idea here is that there are two
functions that we want to explore
so symmetric difference and all
complements they are related
and there are several definitions of how
to compute symmetric differences
okay so yeah let's start here so for
example all complements
will take the complement of each set by
the other ones
i will other ones by the union of the
other ones but the unit of the other
ones yes so the fundamental idea here is
you have several sets and you want to
understand
quickly what is in each one that is not
in the other ones
some sort of differentiator well it's
the unique
elements it could be called unique
elements right that would be an
equivalent name
i think that's a less obscure name i
have to say
yeah it's just very similar to comp just
extending complements
to you know compliments or compliment
compliment yeah compliment it's giving
the compliment between every
it's like an outer product which do you
say is
is more intuitive the unique elements
i think it's unique elements is more
intuitive i agree with that yeah
i think so too i was just justifying how
i arrived at it it was natural
but unique elements is better
so here is that the the function that
is usually defined is this symmetric
difference will take
finally a union
and for example we have already seen
region symmetric difference which is all
the points
that are in one of the sets in in
actually an
odd number of sets that's weird
it's weird but it's a logical definition
that follows
from associativity so if you start from
the two
argument functions and then you request
that the multi-argument function is
associative
then you end up with that definition
okay so
why is this got a list of lists inside
it because that's obviously different
from complement
yes and i see two reasons uh
actually this function has bob
implemented it also accepts the the
the var arc notation but i think it has
to be one or the other because otherwise
they're
yeah otherwise there's no idea the
single tone case is ambiguous
and there is a natural generalization of
this function
which i was considering while analyzing
it which is
what happens if you want the the the
complements by unions of two
other elements or three etc
well i mean to me
um i think it's nice to have it in a
list because you get back a list
well i i i see that that's supposed to
have environments oh yeah i i get it
but i mean i'm trying to think what is
the real use of this so
this is saying unique elements
i i use this a lot so the general
scenarios that i have been computing a
list and long list
by two methods and i want to check that
they are the same and usually they are
not
but i want to know what are the
differences so i have to always do two
complements
and this function would give me directly
the list of the
ones in the first where it's n equals
two so to speak where it's just
two sub lists in there
or imagine going through you know your
credit card statements for a year and
you want to find the things that you
only bought once
right
yes i only bought plane tickets to
florida
yeah for some reason you know it's you
know you only live once you only bought
once
right right never mind i i'm i'm um uh
well okay unique elements that's the
proposed name
yeah personally i like it more with a
single argument
it's the first of args but i'm willing
to be convinced i i agree that i don't i
think we should not
document the rare args form and whether
we have it or not a different issue
okay so now this seems useful
now symmetric difference if i can ever
wrap my brain around what the heck
symmetric difference actually is
so i so go go to the beginning of this
section
so the the fundamental definition is is
just that
the first line
gosh tell me what it is okay
elements that do not appear in both sets
okay
right in all sets okay that's the next
one
so think in terms of venn diagrams so
this one here this one symmetric
difference
is the unique elements function is that
correct
no so the thing is that this symmetric
difference with two arguments
can be generalized in multiple ways and
so i'm discussing here three of them
and that was the thing that confused us
the previous time which one do we choose
so i'm showing here that there are
multiple generalizations and the one
that is
typically used in both in the definition
in wikipedia for example and in our
region symmetric difference
is what i call here associative
symmetric difference
whose fundamental definition is the
fourth line
okay so i mean i understand this is the
analog of our region symmetric
difference
i just think i just don't believe people
are going to use this in programs very
much
i mean when did you last need to use
this i i can't wrap my brain around what
this is supposed to be doing well enough
to even imagine using it
um the truth is that the one i would
certainly use is the other one
the one that still keeps the origin
of where the different diva given
elements which is the unique elements
that you just defined
yes i agree that one is useful that's
why i was agreeing to it
yes but this is the corresponding
function to the one that is usually used
in maths
i understand but but this is look if all
you have is a set theory hammer
everything has to be a set right yeah
and that's what this is doing
i think we should leave this in the
function repository and not build it in
to the system okay okay
now the the one that is in the function
repository
is the first definition which i call the
global generalization
it simply changes the both to all
okay well we can put some of these other
ones in the function repository as well
right yeah that's true
i mean it's one of these things we could
review it again in a year or two
but i just don't see it right now it
just seems like one of these things
where
it's so hard to remember the definition
it's
not a hard function to write
unique elements seems like much more of
a concept that you would want
like i would think every time i thought
about this function i was going to have
to look up its definition
and that's not a good reason to have it
as a named function
i can you click on that link of today
wikipedia because
looking at the venn diagrams it's it's
very helpful to understand
this one
so it's the you're computing these red
regions
yeah i understand
whatever i mean
why would i care
i i understand
uh irwin
is asking why is one symmetric
difference different from all all
compliments the reason is
that in unique elements which is the
rename of
all complements is it's telling you
which list
each unique element was from whereas the
other one is the flatten of this or the
some kind of union flatten of that it's
just telling you which elements are
unique anywhere
as opposed to where they are unique
right
now the the only thing i would say a
potential additional argument in unique
elements
is this idea of right now we are saying
give me
the elements that are in this set but in
none in the other ones
so it could be something like it's in
this one but
not in pairs of the other ones for
example something like that i understand
i can also imagine the unique elements
by
you know there's a certain argument if
there is a well-defined mathematical
definition of symmetric difference we
should just have it
and if it's this crazy thing with
counting even odds
we should just have it because for
people who understand it they can use it
yeah it's the sort of thing that that
name can only mean that
so for somebody then let's have it
and have it mean this crazy even odd
rule just like region symmetric
difference means that right
so it's compatible with that yes and
it's var arc
region symmetric uh difference is one
arc
so i think this should be two yes
fine let's do it
sandra is asking did we discuss a
compliment that takes multiplicity into
account
we didn't what do we have to say about
that
i'm not sure what that is that about
multiset theory
rather than set theory
i guess i mean so yes i guess so i mean
so
we're talking about a complement where
the universal set
where basically what you're doing is i
would imagine
you've got a list and you're removing
from that list
things that occur so let's call it um
you're basically indexing the elements
and removing
the ones with the same indices
i'm not sure what what indices come into
it but i mean in this case what i would
think of that as a1 and a2 oh i see what
you said in the first set
and a1 in the second set
so we have multiset complement in the
function repository
we have multi-set complement in the
function repository that does this
yeah right i mean what this is doing
is deleting elements from one list
i mean really i would i would see this
not so much
this is this is a a list
difference effectively yeah this is just
subtract
elements i mean i agree that this is
quite useful especially in in some kind
of folded
form
i mean i think it's utterly obscure if
we call it multi-set complement nobody
will ever know what it does
the question is here
how do you do well okay so the way you
would do this you would say delete
cases no you couldn't even do that how
would you do this
how would you do this how would you
remove just the two argument form
right how would you remove just those
elements once
do you mean what's implementation what's
the efficient implementation of this
function
yeah what's what's a reasonable
implementation of that function
i i think it would have to be something
that has counters
that's some sort of hash table that
keeps counters
right but right now that's not something
if i want to remove
i bet i've needed to do that a zillion
times
remove elements from a list
you know what i'm saying so that that's
like delete cases but it's kind of like
delete list you get what i'm saying
yep
um and i mean you don't really need the
um
uh
i mean you can sort of uh you know
generalize it up by having that second
thing be patterns
but i think that makes it more obscure
but you don't really need a vera args
form of this because you can just
flatten you can just
you know join all those things together
so to speak
it's not hard to do with italian
it's not super easy to do either right
yeah it's kind of a nuisance
and another important thing here would
be to keep order
i agree i agree i agree
and you can always get rid of the kept
order by doing a you know a sort
this is a good function this is
something as i said i'm sure i've used
it a lot of times
um sandra is asking about complement
counts what is this now so this is
saying
oh that's this function we just defined
right that's that's this um
which one is deleted first who cares if
they're identical
if there aren't patterns
um
okay what's the right name for this
so possible name
this complement what is this
it's like delete cases but it doesn't
have a pattern
it could be multi-set complement you got
to be kidding me
now not kidding i don't know what a
multi-set is i mean of course i do know
what a multi-set is but
that is a you know that's like you are a
set theorist you're a mathematician
you know but this is not for
mathematicians this is where people just
have a
list and they want to get rid of
elements in the list
you know in other words this second list
let's give an example
you know you're processing something or
other
let's see does it remove the first
instance or the last instance
it doesn't matter if it's literals
well it's going to matter if it's
patterns the result will make a
difference if you want to maintain order
right the orders are i think it should
keep the later ones
yeah me too yes i agree
right yeah i thought about list delete
the problem with that is um okay so
delete rather
you know delete is the analog of insert
right it's
positional right
i mean it's sort of like delete first
case
no way no it's not because delete case
is a pattern
right
drop sub list no because drop is always
positional
implement cases complementary cases
no because in other cases
well yeah i mean honestly to me
this goes with delete duplicates
right isn't it like delete elements
which is the analog of delete duplicates
certainly related
and one could imagine that delete
elements
has something where we give the elements
we give the thing and the elements to
delete
and then we could even have an argument
i mean
so for example here okay so this
argument could be
n how many times to delete
up to how many times can you delete each
of these elements
maybe that's crazy no you'd rather just
have them multiple times in the second
argument too
well except for infinity right
but the case of infinity there
i would rather have the third argument
be something like this the case of
infinity is a delete
cases as a fold list fold of delete
cases
right it's just delete cases
no indicatives with alternatives
alternatives right yeah
i'd rather have the the third argument
be like left or right or something that
kind of takes i switched direction
not a level spec that seems like it
should be a level spec to me
delete duplicates doesn't have a level
spec
oh look at that that's whether they
whether they should be considered
duplicates it takes a test
which is different than delete
duplicates by
how i i think this should be
just the same test option
instead of thinking it is uh it's
applied to the parents of the individual
retain excess elements
because the second list
yeah it's well it depends how big the
second list is relative to the first
list
if the second list is two elements in
the first this is a million elements
right
okay so
i agree that if there was any sameness
thing it should be a same test option
and delete elements
well i'm i'm saying uh why do you want a
same test
to handle what
um to decide whether
as you scan this list
is the element that you've given here
the same as the element you've given
here
so for example if i said here let's say
i say a of x
you know c of y etc and here
i say a of blank comma
b for example then what this means is
scan from the left
of these elements
and delete whatever matches that pattern
whatever
i mean it has a certain delete first
character to it
because it is deleting just the first
instance of each of these things
right
delete first instances
that seems to suggest that it's just
going to delete the first and be done
with it
well first of all it's going to use
things up according to what's provided
in the second
argument i mean it reminds me of first
case first position
yeah but it isn't really it's not delete
elements does seem like the right name
because
it's very similar to delete duplicates
delete first elements
plural i think makes it clear
that you're deleting perhaps several
i i prefer deleting elements delete
elements just
there are many functions that start from
the left and it's not hardwired in the
name
no i agree
right
obviously
[Music]
um
multiplicity sanders suggesting
multiplicity's arrow elements
as the second argument oh i see what
you're saying
that's a cute idea
that's a cute idea like the way we do
weightings
that you can say something like two
arrow
ac
which means delete two of a and c
or presumably something like 3 2 arrow
ac
that's a cute idea
does that make sense to people well the
first one
i would interpret as remove two pairs
not remove
two a's and two c's
i mean remove two pairs what do you mean
what yes i would expect that the two
goes to
list ac means look for two pairs in the
list
ac and remove them
no not two a's and two c's separately
oh you mean a total of two things
well no not the total there is no reason
why the a b c
have it couldn't be pairs and then you
have to be able to specify i want to
remove a pair
how does that if they're pairs wait a
minute is this a sequence
thing here or what you're proposing no
just changing the first argument a b to
a pair a comma c
can you remove that or can yes just
change that to a pair
a comma c oh fine right so that two
a comma c means remove two a's and two
c's or
twice the pair a comma c no it's
definitely not twice the pair a comma c
if you just want to do a delete
oh i see what you're saying you're
saying how do i delete just
one element in other words
as a courtesy i could say delete
elements
of abcd
comma c and that would just delete the c
which is the same as complement
except complement doesn't keep the order
i don't think we can apply that courtesy
in the case with elements or lists
right but with the with the rule
notation
i would expect that 2 goes to a remains
means removes twice a
that's what i was meaning 2 goes to a
means remove a
twice exactly so now if we say 2 goes to
list
something i would expect that a has
i understand your point i understand
your point if you have the list three
two goes to whatever
then that's a different story but but
right one
issue here is how does
complement so i think this was what
sander was asking earlier
complement not changing the order
right so delete duplicates
was added because union changes the
order partly
i mean it's correct that union changes
the order because it's treating the list
like a set
do you mean delete cases no i mean
delete duplicates was added
to union delete duplicates is the same
as union except it doesn't change the
order
yeah yeah sorry right so
so now the question is what is the
analog complement
that doesn't change the order
because that's what we're talking about
here i think
in the one argument well i yeah i mean
this is
this is okay
delete duplicates is to union as this
function
is to complement
is that a true statement
well i think my confusion is that delete
union
can take one argument or several
arguments
and the duplicates can only take one i'm
sorry which is a
union oh i'm yeah okay i'm talking about
the one argument form of unit
right okay and i'm claiming that this
function
like complement can take is very logs
also
yes but complement of one argument
doesn't make sense no compliment of two
arguments
which is i mean this function which
print preserves order
is really not that relevant in the
veradox case
right but i think my point is that there
the proper relation of complement with
two arguments is union with two
arguments which has no analogue
in delete duplicates
okay but i don't think that's relevant i
think what we're saying is that the
this is the question is how would i use
c how would i make a compliment
that doesn't that preserves order
right and the answer is this function
will be such a function
delete elements is complement preserving
order
but only in the two argument case
except it also you know maintains
multiplicity
so you have to say infinity goes to
wait a minute wait wait wait wait wait
delete duplicates
obviously by its nature does not
maintain multiplicity
right because it makes only one of
everything
right so this is i agree this is again a
little different because
right it is maintaining this is
different than the two argument
complements in two ways
one it maintains order and two it
maintains multiplicity
right so to prevent it maintaining
multiplicity that's what we're talking
about these
you know thing arrow whatever right so
it could be infinity
and then it would be the it would be
just like two argument complements
but maintaining order
um
steve is pointing out that if there was
telemetry on all our functions it would
be interesting to see what's used what
the latest used function least used
functionalities etc etc
yes yes yes yes yes i mean look there's
a trade-off
in version 0.9 of mathematica back in
1987
we had such telemetry and it was
frustrating because it was you know we
got a fair amount of data we didn't
really know what to do with it
there were all kinds of privacy issues
and
it's like we weren't that excited about
it i mean for example in the cloud
you know the server does know although
we don't
you know for largely for privacy reasons
we don't
uh we don't even collect aggregated data
on that although we certainly could
um yes i agree it would be interesting
to know that stuff
i mean we we have some proxies like the
the number of times documentation pages
are looked at and stuff like this
sandra is by the way commenting that our
single symbol form can't possibly work
and i think i agree with that
i mean we could make
um
i see i mean as a courtesy we could make
the single symbol thing work but i think
it's kind of crazy
only for non-list elements which would
be confusing
what do you mean non-list elements you
mean things which aren't lists
yes yes yeah i mean things which aren't
lists i don't know how confusing that
would be i mean we have other cases of
that
right if you're just used to the single
form because you've used it with all
sorts of expressions
and then you try to do it with a list
and it doesn't work only in the case of
lists
it's a little weird yeah i wouldn't do
that we have already deleted cases to do
that
wait a minute delete cases delete all of
them right it doesn't just delete one of
them
right yeah but
yeah i would still require having a list
around it
i think that's the only thing we should
document for sure
yes yeah steve is commenting that
knowing more about how functions were
used would support design decisions i
agree with you
up to a point i think it's one of these
cases where it's like a b
testing for websites by the time it's
down to a b testing
yep you can do it if you say should my
website
you know how should my website be
designed let's just test it
it's like good luck the space is much
too big to test
um and and i think by the time we are
deploying by the time we're sort of a b
testing language designs
that's completely unfair to users
because like you're going to write code
and it's going to be in one form or the
other
and that's like super confusing but i
agree it'll be nice to know
you know we do have some popularity
measures because we know code that's out
there in the world we know how frequent
functions are in that code
that's out there in the world and we
have that data it's involved in language
data
so that's not a terrible proxy an
example something we'd really like to
know right now is
which we realize we have almost no data
on is
what kind of typing mistakes do people
make or what kind of
mistakes do people make before they ever
get their function
into the system you know what kinds of
input errors do they make
we'd really like to know that because it
informs our code
assistance mechanisms all right i think
we've got a good new function this
delete elements thing i think is a very
useful new function
and we'll have delete elements
unique elements and symmetric difference
that's a that's a big pile of functions
for this short amount of time
alright should we move on um sorry
can we compare a bit in unique elements
with
delete elements one is one arc the other
is not
is that okay delete elements still can
take any number of lists right
i wasn't thinking that way i was
thinking it's just two lists
i see i would start with just two
lessons and see what happens
the design does not foreclose us on
larger numbers
now the only thing i don't think we've
defined is a single number
arrow a list what does it mean
well remember we don't support anything
other than a list of elements in the
second element
there so that means the only question is
does that mean
two in aggregate from that list or does
that mean
two-two arrow ac
the two in aggregate is not something we
can get
any other way exactly
let's hit our max items option
yeah and do we support a list of rules
just in case we want two a and three c
no
it's ambiguous
the only way we can do this the only
reason we can do this is because it's
same as a bunch of other functions
the outermost level of that second
argument is either a rule or a list
if it is a list as the outermost element
then nothing inside it is elements to
delete
right okay so if we want different
numbers we put at least
also in the first argument of rule i
think so
but but the only question is it two is
it aggregate two
i think we're saying yes because that's
additional functionality
right sandra is commenting that analogy
with the weights to random choice
it should always be a list but that's
the whole point it's not precisely
yes that that was the pattern that i was
using and thinking about this design
go ahead you're going to say something
jose
um i'm sorry i
just forgot okay no problem all right
should we go on
okay symbols
yes so this time the the various
functions are good this is by the way
exactly supporting steve's comments
because we actually have popularity
ranks here
but go ahead out of about 2 000
to get a better scale okay
what is this this is handling of symbols
is that what you're saying here
yes so this time the the symbols are
grouped into some sort of categories
no but yes i understand but meta
this is first category no this first
category
is symbols about symbols exactly
okay
that's cool
i didn't know even had that how does
that possibly work
it's only in the current session as
implemented
you can you can do this with a front-end
token
i see so i mean to me we were just
talking about this a day or two ago
in the context of code assistance which
by the way is a meeting that we
should probably live stream um
but uh um
note for the next time let's discuss
doing that yeah i got it oh
i mean some aspects of it were well
quite boring but but i'm not this time
but they have been in the past so
they've not been
appropriate um
although actually those have been
they've been interesting if you're
interested in ux
design um not so interesting from a
language design point of view
although becoming more so now uh
okay but what we discussed there
is general syntax
templates
this needs a discussion with i assume
there's nobody from the front-end team
here
to talk about this one
i mean this whole question about how you
add auto completions
just seems like a thing we should be
able to do in general
i don't even know what this does where
it adds the auto completion etc
for each of the our guy
well i'm a little confused by this can
we um
can we get somebody from the front end
team here to to um
uh not not today
but another time to address this
okay gut unbound symbols
the heck is that
oh i see
hey yeah yeah yeah okay i mean these are
these are somewhat useful but i'm just
i don't know about this one this one
this one i mean if
let's just do a little bit of triage of
ones that really jump out at us
as useful
i don't know why these aren't i see this
is find all
symbols with a particular option yeah i
mean that's kind of obscure
possible name cue
is more like a syntax cube question
isn't it kinda
it's basically just name cue but the
symbol doesn't have to exist yet
where is this useful
uh just like for example in the resource
function code it tests
that your resource function name should
also be a valid symbol name
i see seems specialized to me
all right let's just go and see all of
these are all of these are for the
for the hardcore developer the ones
right in that first
section
yeah this one is interesting
ethan is saying we should add an
unsupported in cloud
to the function repository good point
good point
i wonder whether this one works in the
cloud does it
that's not well but
how do we not know that so to speak
it's a good point we should at least
have a way for the author to declare it
and then show it on the page
even if we're not verifying
everyone
i mean let's see whether that one just
blows itself to pieces
splaff that would be a category i don't
know where the qa
tests function repository functions in
the cloud do they
i don't think so they probably should
i mean like for example if i do cloud
evaluate of this
i'm sure it'll be the exact same i mean
yeah
you couldn't imagine that would do
anything helpful anyway no i understand
that
right that would at least tell you okay
so this is the thing to bring up with qa
this is for addison i guess to bring up
with qa
loaded um
okay
this is certainly something i've needed
from time to time
this it's very interesting it's rank is
not spectacular
because we've considered until like like
many times over the last 35 years
okay steve is saying plot function
popularity against last revision date
um yeah i mean there's a question of how
how quickly should we wrap something
brother i don't think our text
recognizes complaining that ocr is kind
of old
i think our ocr thing has been revised
fairly recently it's pretty state of the
art
if i remember correctly i think it was
revised in
maybe a version of go let's take a look
we can um
updated in 2020.
there's something wrong with it it's not
through lack of attention
um
emc is commenting that obviously
open language functions have larger test
suites absolutely they do
the problem is we have not been testing
the function repository
as carefully as we've been testing
internal code because
the tests here are these functions
are not signed up to be no corner cases
they're signed up to you know you've got
the source code if you don't like it
you know go look at the source code go
modify it type thing it's kind of the
usual
the usual story of sort of open source
code type
type things um as opposed to
you know it's it's really guaranteed to
work and continue working but but yes
it's an oversight probably on our part
that we are incorrectly assuming that
certain functions
because our underlying functions work
well
okay so the real correct thing to do is
to ask the question from more from
language data is any of
our any of the functions in the
implementation of this function
cloud you know
do they have a problem in the cloud if
none of the functions in the
implementation have a problem in the
cloud
yeah we could test in the cloud but it's
just for amusement value
right and that was a good example that
was three lines of code but one of them
was an undocumented front-end
function right so even if we were
running against the list of things that
we know don't work in cloud it wouldn't
flag it
so we would have to run it against a
white list
of things that we do know working cloud
to even have a suspicion
well right so this one here well no i
mean this would be
there is a function here there's a good
example there is a function here that is
not in our white list of things that are
thought to work in the cloud
right right but yeah we wouldn't be
maintaining a blacklist we'd be
maintaining whitelist which which we
have
i mean something and i mean it's worth
remembering that's not just does it work
in the cloud it's like
can it be in a scheduled task can it be
done with remote evaluate
does it require a camera does it you
know there's a there's a lot of
difficulty
a lot of those compatibility things are
going to be
expanded out with pacquiao repository
and then
it'll work its way back into other
repositories as well
perkinji observes that a project should
naturally translate itself to open
source or perish
you know we've been alive for 35 years
so i think we're okay
and we seem to have a pretty good model
um
and for many years much of our code was
open and nobody cared
so we stopped um and there are many
reasons
many reasons some of which will not be
obvious to you why
it would be a bad idea um
and uh
plus also i think people are realizing
that the whole
you know it's just open it's all free
is always [ __ ] because in the end
you know if you can if somebody's doing
real work somebody's going to end up
paying for it
and the only question is are the people
who are getting benefit paying for it or
is somebody else paying for it
and the people who think they're getting
benefit are actually
uh you know some weird thing is
happening but we could
give a long exposition of that but we're
always interested in
you know who knows what the future of
these things will be
we are experimenting with many different
code licensing models like our compiled
code will have all kinds of
different kinds of openness uh
characteristics which i am not hopeful
will lead to any
contributions um
it's sort of interesting though the
model that we've had
which we started 35 years ago
our model has survived whereas many
other models have crashed and burned
in the intervening years so that's a
thing worth realizing
um
and has allowed us to continue to be
you know to innovate and build new stuff
for 35 years
which i consider to be not bad
considering that
you know the total age of the oldest
you know computers have only been around
for what 70 years or something
um you know that's a respectable
fraction of the total time that
computers have been around
so anyway uh
all right well there's lots more to look
at here i know i'm running into
uh time for the next meeting um
what an earth does random string do
that's trivial
it's based on alphabet you presumably
specify an alphabet
or it's just english i i think you can
specify a character set yeah
but i think the default is i'll randomly
choose promise out of characters
yeah yeah well i've certainly needed
this i mean this is this is not
useless right we have things like random
color and
yeah all these little random things that
are really convenient
random things that are random that
generate random things yes
exactly yeah i agree i mean you know
i've many times i've wanted a random
base pair sequence or something and
obviously i can make it i just say
random choice
of that thing and then say string join
of it
this is kind of weird
well anyway uh we should come back again
i'm just curious what some of these
other ones are
i don't know why these aren't part of
encrypt
these things
i this is not something we're going to
have a top level i mean this is like
compatibility with
antiquity so to speak
well could call it classical cipher
and then why would we want that why is
it not just part of encrypt doesn't it
do the same thing that encrypt does
but just in a very lame way possibly
i mean in other words encrypt is taking
you know you've got a key
so okay so i agree that encrypt has a
really fancy key in general
or password or something whereas the
caesar cipher just has a number
although one could certainly imagine
allowing an arbitrary password and you
derive a number from that password
although i have to admit that the
thought of a key derivation function for
a caesar cipher is a bit weird
yeah i i strongly think these other
cyphers should be built into encrypt
um for which we probably need at this
meeting
people who've been involved in the like
daario who've been involved in the
implementation of encrypt
right the method option is pretty it's
sort of complicated here
it'd be nice if you could just say
method goes to affine
but yeah right now it takes an
association with
you know sub options we thought you
could just say
a single name if you wanted to it will
default the other stuff
these mostly have sub
option settings what what you'd consider
sub-option settings
the key string for visionnaire that kind
of thing
sorry which has a caesar cipher or the
encrypt right now
i'm saying if if we add these to encrypt
we're still going to want
sub-option settings for these
for caesar ciphers and things sure yes
yeah just like we have them for i mean
these ones here
um i mean
i think we've got to look at putting i
mean to me
i don't know whether any of these is an
enigma machine or something but you know
we probably should have an encrypt that
encrypts like an enigma machine
and the only feature of these is that
for encrypt we don't make it especially
easy to get out the encrypted data
right i think we can get it out but it
isn't particularly
um how do we get this out
well if we look at the input form here
yeah so i mean for example
okay so so here right so this would say
cypher arrow caesar
it might have some options and then
instead of a
you know data would presumably not be a
byte array
it would presumably just be a string for
the caesar cipher case
yeah sense
and you know i don't know whether we can
say of data here to get out the data
hey that's weird what on earth happened
there
is that a bug hold on let's let's try
that again
okay i type an open bracket i type
quotes data
no who knows okay so that indeed pulls
out the biter eye
so that would be typically what you
would actually want to get out in the
case of the caesar cipher
rather than an opaque encrypted object
and i really need to go to another
meeting here
um well good we
we three you know
traffic new functions that we defined
lots of other stuff
to look at um we really should be
you know making sure that in these
meetings that we are doing some fresh
new functions that have come
uh that have come through and only uses
a backup
background task going through the
function repository functions
does that make sense to people i didn't
understand that
i'm saying that there's a stream of
things that are coming into ild
often from me and i'm saying let's make
sure we decently prioritize those things
instead of always going through
functional positive functions
yes as we commented we were trying to
kind of uh work through this
pile of communication
okay well fine fine i i they're not
super fast as we can see
yeah yeah and the good thing is they
already exist in the function repository
and how do you yes so that's the full
guys in them
say that again how do you know we're not
prior advertising them
closing what the things that come from
you
that stream
maybe we just like these more okay okay
okay prioritizing as in
not prior oratizing
but oratizing somehow
yeah you know this
what an earth is asynchronous dynamic
module
huh that sounds like a good idea
it's it's good
well maybe it should be dynamic part of
the module yeah
that's right that's why there's that
note there an extension dynamic module
sounds like a good thing sounds like we
need somebody from the front end team
here to discuss that um
this would be lou i'm pretty sure i
would think so
i think he had that resource function
too didn't he
might have been my clue oh no right i
think it was
now that you mentioned no no okay
interesting
we got a nice contribution to the
potential contribution of the function
repository from don knuth yesterday
although i think it needs a bit of
cleanup but um
i think jose got got sent that
um
okay i better go to my other meeting
right um
well thanks guys thank you to folks on
livestream good suggestions